kid rock has officially announced his
candidacy for the US Senate yeah
that's a true story I didn't make that
up Kid Rock yeah
Kid Rock says he wants to restore
America back to a better time when it
would have been unimaginable for Kid
Rock to run I love that these days you
hear that you go yeah okay I guess why
not
right let it wreck Nassau while he's at
it yeah vice president chia-pet
oh maybe the new Republican health care
bill is out and the bad news is older
people still pay more than younger
people yeah yeah of course the good news
is they don't pay more for long
I just enjoyed your reaction to that so
much they were just like I could see a
crowd starting to realize hey I'm pretty
young all right they're gonna love me
yeah hey this is the big news ladies and
gentlemen President Trump and the first
lady are visiting France they're in
France yeah
now there have been some
misunderstandings due to the language
barrier like at dinner when Melania was
offered a crepe and she said no thanks
I'm married to one
[Applause]
yeah it was stupid uh Republican
Republican House Speaker Paul Ryan is
calling for stronger sanctions against
Russia for its election meddling yes yes
yes that's what he said yeah that's
Republican yeah Ryan said we must keep
Russia out of our elections until we
need them again in 2018
not got one of those not so funny but
smart he's got to do at least one of
those NBC's long-running reality show
The Biggest Loser has been canceled
yeah or as NBC put it we just lost
30,000 pounds
that's too late now all right we all
know what happened there okay you're ten
second later clap did nothing to help
the situation get this gang I do this
when I mean business
a new study just came out that's right a
study came out I've got your attention
now study came out found that breast
implants can save your life if you're
shot in the chest
[Applause]
yeah amazing in a related story The Real
Housewives of Beverly Hills just joined
SEAL Team six
[Applause]
you